Welcome, ladies and gents,
to the much anticipated modules.
Now we're going deep into actually understanding our playbook,
understanding how to backtest,
how to test the system, how to collect the data,
how to essentially split tests across variables
that are inside of your system
and start really treating trading like a business
and like a data analyst.
So in this video,
I'm gonna kinda just walk you through my playbook,
walk you through the rules of the playbook,
and then walk you through my tagging system.
So without further ado, let's kinda go and get started.
Now, here we are in Zella,
I've got a fresh account going,
and I have here my playbook, right?
The specific playbook that we're gonna be looking at
in this module,
which is the M15 Intraday Bias model.
For you guys, most commonly known as, you know,
pro-trained M15,
lower time frame confirmation,
that model that we trade.
So if we kinda just go in here,
essentially if you come into trade Zella
and you wanted to create a playbook, right?
You can just open this little area in here
that is called create playbook, click this little icon,
and then here you will kinda see general information,
it's where you can kind of add an icon
or choose a color, whatever it is,
and then name your playbook.
Now, there's no such thing as, you know,
the right name for a playbook,
it's just whatever name that you decide to give it.
This is more so just for you to, you know,
know what playbook it is.
And so there's no right or wrong name for a strategy,
you don't need to name your playbook
the same as my playbook if you don't want to.
So you can name your playbook,
and then you can give it a little bit of a description.
And then once you've done this, right,
so let's just say we're gonna call it Intraday,
and then let's just say this is basically M15 Bias.
Once you've kind of created your overall name
and description of your playbook,
then this is where you're gonna go
into your trading playbook rules.
Now, one thing here that you can do is you can go
and watch the actual, you can go in here
and look at how trades are explained the playbook,
but for me personally, it's just not necessary.
It's just not necessary.
It's very simple.
Obviously here, we have entry criteria,
exit criteria, market conditions.
You don't necessarily have to have these.
You can essentially create a new group yourself.
And so for example, you know,
you want to be, when you create a playbook,
you want to just be looking at what are the groups of rules, right?
So for example, one of them is we have Bias, right?
Now, one of the rule group is Bias.
Another rule group could be entry criteria,
another could be exit criteria, right?
That's essentially how you create your kind
of overarching rule groups.
And then inside of each one, you can create rules.
And so for example, here you have the name of the rule.
And so for a Bias rule, for me,
I need to be pro-trend M15 for this model.
And the pro-trend M15 is relative to the external swing points
of structure following the three-candle pullback model.
And so we can see this is the rule.
The rule for my bias is that the trend,
I must be trading in alignment with the trend on the M15.
And then this rule should be applicable when?
Is this rule available?
Should this rule be followed always, regardless,
no matter what, when it's a winner,
when it's a loser, when the trade is a breakeven.
So for a bias, it's always required.
So that becomes an always, right?
Versus, let's say, an exit criteria.
Now in an exit criteria, what you might have is a, you know,
50% partial at five risk to reward, right?
And so that's your rule.
Your rule is that you take off 50% of your open position
at five R, and then do you do that always?
Oh no, because not every single trade runs to five R.
So you only do that when the trade is a winner.
So now you have a rule that is close 50% of the position
at five R, if that trade is a winner.
Another one, you can have, you know,
when a trade is a breakeven.
So a trade is breakeven when the one minute timeframe,
break structure, right, after an entry,
and there's no reason for price to return.
All right, that's the, that's the rule.
So when you get a one minute break of structure,
after your entry, so a one minute continuation,
and there's no reason for price to return
to your entry level, meaning there's no five minute order
block or five minute fair value gap at that,
at that absolute price level where you've entered,
there's no reason for price to return.
Therefore, if this happens, then we go to breakeven.
And so now we've created a new rule.
If the one minute break structure, once we're in the trade,
and there's no reason for price to return to that level,
we can actually move that trade to breakeven, right?
It's as simple as that.
And so that becomes a rule.
And so that is essentially how you create rules.
Now your playbook isn't some really in-depth,
detailed system.
It's an overarching collection of principles
that you follow, and you go deeper
with what we have as our tagging system.
So I'll cancel this one for now,
and we'll go into the actual playbook that we have,
and I'll show you the rules.
So again, you can see completely fresh account,
completely fresh playbook,
and now we can go into the rules of this playbook.
And you can just find playbooks in here,
in the backtest and feature, playbooks, is where it'll be.
So for me, these are the rules I have.
I have a rule for bias,
and that rule is that the M15 must be pro-trend always.
Plain and simple.
Then I have another rule for my area of interest.
My area of interest is tied to the area of price,
but I would look at potentially getting into the market
if I get the confirmation.
So that area of interest is either a strong point of interest
or a liquidity sweep, right?
A strong point of interest or liquidity sweep.
And again, the difference between strong and weak
and a lot of sorts of points of interest,
that would be kind of clarified later.
But I always need to have either a strong point of interest
or a liquidity sweep, right?
For me to get involved in market
and I should actually be more specific here,
or session liquidity sweep.
So in Asia or London, right?
That is my rules.
Anytime that I need to enter the market
or I'm getting ready to enter a trade,
I first have to make sure that I'm in a strong point
of interest or I've had a sweep of session liquidity.
Then we have entry criteria.
So this is the criteria that I will use
to enter into a trade.
And so always, every trade that I take
must be an M1 change of character or break of structure,
a line of M15, right?
So the M15 is bullish and that's the first one by us.
I'm looking for longs.
Then if we enter an area of interest,
which is either a strong POI
or a session sweep of liquidity,
then I can look at my entry.
But to enter, I would need to see a one minute change
of character or break of structure aligned with the M15.
So usually if the M15 is trading higher,
then as price comes back down to sweep of session liquidity
or into a point of interest,
the one minute timeframe is usually going to be bearish.
In that case where it's bearish,
once we get to my area of interest,
my job is to wait for the price to shift
from bearish to bullish inside of that area.
And if it is already shifted to bullish,
then there could be an instance
where I can't trade the first change of character.
I have to wait for a break of structure.
And again, those are the specific details
that will be outlined and made clear in our tagging system.
So that is the first entry rule.
The second entry criteria is what I use to enter the market.
So I'm always using anything between M1 and M5,
either an order block or fevaiga, M1, M2, M3, M5,
order block or fevaiga.
I know it's a little bit vague and a little bit broad,
but the reality is,
is what you use, whether it be a fair value gap
or whether it be in the order block,
is contextual to the actual price feed itself.
So there'll be some instances where we use order block.
There'll be some instances where we use a fair value gap.
And it's our job in the moment
to decipher which one we should use.
And most importantly, why we decided to use that one,
which again will be highlighted in much more detail
when we're kind of running through the tests.
Then we have the management.
So at this point, I've already got a bias
and I only trade if I'm with that bias.
So it goes like this, bias, pro trend, yes.
Okay, now you can move on, pro trend, no, don't do anything.
So always pro trend, area of interest.
Okay, with pro trend, cool, I'm looking for lungs,
area of interest, question mark, yes, great.
Strong POI or session equality, no, do nothing, right?
That's simple.
Okay, your pro trend, you're in an area of interest.
Okay, M1, change of character or break of structure?
Yes, okay, now you can look at entering the trade.
No, don't do anything.
Okay, now you're looking to enter the trade.
Do you have a M1 or M5, M1, M3, M5 in that region
order block or fair value gap to trade from, right?
Yes, okay, great, go for it.
No, okay, hold your horses, wait for a second,
let's get more confirmation.
Now we're going to management.
So one time in the trade, these first three principles
are essentially what get me into the trade.
Then the management is how I'm getting out of the trade.
So the management, the first one, this is when a trade
is break even, the M1 will break structure after the entry
and there's no need for a return, right?
So my break even rule is, and this is management, right?
I should close my trade at break even if the one minute
break structure after I've already entered
and there's no need for return.
If that happens, stop loss goes to break even.
If that trade gets closed, I follow my rules, right?
So that's simple.
So then we have for a stop loss.
So when I trade is a loser, it will be a break
of the protected structural low that I entered from.
So if I'm waiting for a M1 change of character
to get involved in the market, then I'm basically trading
that new bullish price leg or bearish price leg on the M1.
And so my stop loss is always going below the structured,
below the protected structural low for longs
and above the protected structural high for short.
And so if that area gets traded through,
then I get stop loss.
And so that's very simple.
Now this is the management rule, right?
When I trade is a winner, I will close half the position
at five restore award.
So if I'm in this trade and it's going in my favor,
if it hits five restore award, I close half of my position.
That is my rule, right?
And then this is how I kind of scale out the rest
of the position, which can be a little bit more subjective
in the moment.
But again, you're going to be seeing me do this time
and time again over this next kind of year-long backtest
and you'll understand how I'm scaling up my positions.
So the principle is that I scale out at structural levels
and I close half of the position each time.
So let's say we take five R, right?
And let's say the N target, which is the M15 swing high,
is 15 R because we're in a huge price lake.
I don't want to hold that entire 15 R
and hope that price trades straight through it.
There may be some instances where that's the case.
But what I'm looking for is on the way there,
do we have an old Asia session high?
Do we have an old New York high?
Do we have an old London high?
An old weak high that we can use as liquidity
to exit our position.
And each time I close my position,
I'm closing half of what's left open.
So if I close half at five R,
now I have 50% of my total risk left open,
which is 0.5%.
Then if we get to 10 R,
then I'm going to close half of what's open.
So I'm going to close 0.25% at 10 R,
which is going to net me another 2.5.
And then maybe have another target, right?
And then eventually, let's say I have only three targets,
it's going to be five R, I close half at let's say 10 R,
that's the target at 10 R,
then I close another half, which is 0.25%.
And then let's say the end target is 15 R,
then I close the final 0.25% because it's half,
because you don't half it on the end one,
you need to close in full, right?
If there was another target, then it would just be half.
Hopefully that makes sense.
So that's the management system.
And again, you'll see all of this play out in real time.
And then I have two rules to follow for news.
So I always need to follow this rule.
No trading on a session with CPI NFP or FMC.
So it's always going to be obviously New York session.
So if I know that there's CPI that day,
if I know there's NFP that day,
or if I know that there's FOMC that day,
I'm not to trade that specific New York session,
point blank period.
Now, this is a little bit of a,
well, it's still just important.
I always need to follow this rule.
And that is don't enter a trade
before we get retail sales or core PC, right?
Those are two news events that occur at 830 AM EST,
smack bang in the middle of my trading window,
that I don't want to be in a trade
when those news events get released,
because we could see significant price spikes,
and that could lead to very much the deflation of my edge.
So don't enter before retail sales and core PC.
Now, that's my playbook, right?
Those are my rules.
Every time I take a trade,
I have to checklist those things.
But we can go deeper into tags,
and this is where we really organize the data.
So this is the playbook.
This is the system that gets followed no matter what.
But then within this system,
there are many different variables that occur
that are slightly different.
So kind of layer one of building an edge
is building just a simple playbook like this,
and then taking everything that fit in alignment with that.
No, nothing wrong with that.
Totally fine.
Can totally build a great profitable edge.
But if you want to take it to a new level,
and this is where refining your edge comes into things,
what you want to do is you want to look
at every different portion of the puzzle,
and then try to start breaking them down
into different variables, right?
And then start tagging the variables,
because at the end of all the testing,
along as you tag everything correctly,
now when you go and view the data,
you're not just viewing the success of the playbook itself.
You also get to view the success
of the details of the playbook.
And what you might find is some of the little variables
that you've put inside because you want to test them,
you may find substantial differences in the results.
And so if I walk through the kind of tagging system
that we're going to be using for this hypothesis,
then you'll begin to understand what I'm saying.
And at the end, when we review all the data,
you'll be able to see everything full picture.
So don't worry if you're a little bit confused right now.
Everything will start to make sense.
And then final part of the playbook
is this little note section in here.
Now, this is the note section for the playbook.
So the way that you can use this,
I won't really be using it in this specific module,
but the way you can use this is if you have a playbook
and you're testing and you start noticing things,
but you don't want to just completely disrupt the test
and just, okay, I've noticed this thing three times now.
So I'm going to go read the test and it's like, no,
you can call yourself a lot of havoc.
So what you want to do is you want to use this note system
in your playbook, use this note system
and then start adding things that you may find, right?
And so if there's a specific something that happened
and it kind of captures your attention.
You're like, hey, that happened.
I don't want to forget that happened
because I may want to come back to that at a later date
and start running some kind of hypothetical test,
including this thing that I realize.
Maybe what you realize is that when Asia High
is a swing and the internal structure is aligned with M15,
the Asia High doesn't get swept.
And so on those days, you can't take a trade
because you need that Asia session high to have been swept.
And so you might want to note that down
and then you might want to add some details.
And so you might want to categorize your note as like,
you might want to give it a little heading
and then you want to go into context, right?
You can upload some things.
Maybe you want to upload images or anything like that.
You can basically use this as an organizational area
to take notes for this specific playbook
so that you can come back constantly
and you can kind of just look at all your notes
and then decide what you want to do with them, right?
Maybe you took a bunch of notes
and at the end of it, you realized that
I don't really, you know,
I've seen that thing a couple of times
but it didn't really have that big of an impact.
And the edge is really good and, you know,
there's nothing I really need to do with that.
Or maybe you need to come back and you look at that
and you're like, yeah,
that's something that I definitely need
to understand a little bit more.
And that's something that I definitely need
to run some tests on.
And so now you have that instead of just writing it down
on a piece of pen and paper or just identifying it
and just hoping that you see it.
What this does is again, it's your operating system, right?
You want to be taking everything
and kind of comprising it into the specific area
that it needs to be so that no stone gets left unturned.
And so that is essentially the playbook in itself.
Then you actually have your tags.
So if you go into settings and you go into tags management,
this is where you can add tags, right?
And tags are a really essential part of your trading
and the way I look at tags personally,
some people may look at it differently.
Here's how I personally look at tags and use tags.
I want to use categories of tags
to look at specific, deeper layer details.
And so for example, we have our playbook.
That's our trading strategy.
But there are a variety of different setups.
So here you can see I have a category that is named setups.
And if I go into my actual tags
and then I filter by setups,
what you'll see here is that these are all
of the different setups that can occur inside of that playbook.
So it's no longer just follow these rules
and take this trade, it's yes, follow these rules
every single time.
But now let's start looking at categorizing them.
So these are the setups.
So now every time I take a trade,
I'm not just collecting the data on the playbook's performance.
I'm also simultaneously collecting the data
on the intricate details of the playbook.
So I can come in and if I have all of the different setups
at the end when I have my finalized data for my playbook,
now I can start to understand,
okay, well, what's my best setup, right?
Maybe the London sweep on Asia is my best setup.
Maybe when Frankfurt sweeps Asia
and then gives me the reversal,
that's actually my worst quality of setup.
So what I've done is I've taken all the different setup types
that I so commonly see and would be willing to test
and put them into a category called setups.
And then every trade I take,
I will tag that trade with what setup it is.
And so at the end again, I can go and filter for the data
and my playbook may say one thing,
but now if I go and zoom in
and I see all of the different setups,
I'll be able to see the trading performance
of all of those setups individually.
And what you'll find is that maybe your playbook
has a 40% win rate, but when you go into setups,
maybe one of your setups has a 70% win rate,
maybe one of your setups has a 20% win rate.
And that's how it kind of averages out
and you get your overall forks and win rate.
Now what you do with that data is totally up to you.
You can do whatever you want with that data.
That is on you.
I can't tell you what to do with your data.
I can just show you how to truly operate
like a professional trader,
like a proper data analyst
and ultimately treating trading
like it is the business that it is.
And so what I'll do now is I'll walk you
through the different setups very briefly
and you'll get a decent level understanding of them.
But again, like I said,
when we're actually running this properly
day in day out in the testing period,
you'll very quickly come to terms
and understand what they are.
So we have our setup types.
Now there are essentially three different setups
for London session that I've characterized
that we're going to be testing.
And there are five different setups
for New York session that I've categorized
and that we're going to be testing.
So we can kind of jump straight in.
Let's start with the first New York session.
So the first New York session variation
of setup is the New York continuation
from London point of interest.
Very simple setup, right?
This is trading from a point of interest
created between London Open and New York Open.
So if we're trending like so
and the swing low or somewhere in the region
of the swing low is, you know, London session
and we give a break of structure and we trade higher.
And New York comes back down to that area of interest
created from that London volatility,
then we trade from that.
And obviously we trade with the same entry model
every single time, which is the change of character.
And then we trade that.
The second model is the New York sweep of London.
So again, you can see here with pro trend,
swing low, swing high, we have a London session low.
Now, if New York sweeps that London session low,
we don't need to be in a area of interest, right?
It could be an extra confluence.
This is what the tagging system is all about.
But it doesn't need to be from an area of interest.
Does it need to be from a fair value gap or an order block?
It just needs to be able to sweep that London session
and give us our entry confirmation from New York session, right?
The third setup is the New York sweep of Asia.
Again, very simple thing.
We're bearish, right?
Swing high goes to swing low.
And we have Asia session high in here.
New York opens and sweeps above that Asia session.
Again, don't need to be in an order block
or a fair value gap.
We could be and we'll tag that, but we don't need to be.
And we get a lower time frame shift.
We enter and it's the same rules again that apply.
Then you have the low sweep London New York continuation.
So this is when the low area of price
and low pretty much stands for an area of a gap
or an area of inactivity or calm,
which for us is our inactive window
between London and New York session.
So this typically occurs from 5 a.m. till 7 a.m.
So that's two hour window.
If in that to our window,
we get a sweep of London's high
and then we get a change of character in that window,
right on the woman time frame.
Then when New York session opens,
we wait for another break of structure to the downside
and then we can enter.
So that requires us to have a continuation.
Then we also have the low sweep London New York reversal.
And this is essentially pretty similar,
but it's the low period between 5 and 7 a.m.
that sweeps London,
but the change of character for our entry occurs in New York.
So we sweep London in the low session,
but we actually change character
and confirm our entry in the New York window.
When that happens, you don't need to wait for a continuation.
You can just trade straight from the reversal, right?
So those are our New York session setups.
Then we have our London setups.
And so the first one is the London sweeps Asia model, right?
Some of you are obviously already very familiar with this model.
This is very simple.
We're in a pro trend, swing low, swing high,
we have Asia session low and London session sweeps Asia low
and then we have a reversal.
Does it need to be from an area of interest?
Does it need to be in premium discount?
All of those are variables
and that's what we're gonna be testing separately
so that at the end we can collect all the independent variables
and then essentially make our playbook better, right?
That's the entire purpose of this video.
The entire purpose of this video
isn't and this entire series, to be honest with you,
isn't just to give you a crystal clear,
already fully refined edge.
Although that's what you will essentially get
at the end of it.
It's really about showing you how to be a trading operator
so that, you know, God forbid, I disappear tomorrow
and let's say, you know, all of this was removed.
If you have this information,
you could go and build a playbook yourself
with any trading concept.
That's what I always say.
I believe, truly, that I could take any concepts
and somehow turn them into a profitable edge
because I understand how to organize data,
how to test, how to review that data
and then try to make changes according to that data.
So that's the London Sweeps Asia.
Then you have the Frankfurt sweep of London.
So the Frankfurt session essentially occurs
between Asia's session and London's session open.
So there's this two-hour window between midnight,
which is Asia's session and this is all EST,
so in midnight and two AM.
That two-hour window is our Frankfurt session.
So if Frankfurt sweeps Asia, right,
and changes character on the one minute timeframe,
so give us a confirmation,
then in the London session,
we need to see a continual break of structure
on the one minute timeframe.
And if we get that continuation,
then we can look at entering into the market, right?
And then finally, we have the Frankfurt sweeps Asia,
London continuation,
which is essentially just Frankfurt sweeps Asia,
but the change of character occurs in London
and you can also trade that model.
And we're gonna be seeing, you know,
do what of these models work,
what are these models that don't work?
If there's something that doesn't work,
we're gonna disregard it.
If something does work,
we're gonna understand and look at it
and then we're gonna go deeper into the details
and understand what makes it better,
what makes an A+ set up, right?
This is how you truly build a playbook
and truly understand your edge at the deepest of levels.
And so that is essentially the different setup variables.
Now, back to the playbook for a minute
because I wanna explain something
and this is something that you'll obviously come
to a lot more clarity and understanding
when we're running the back test,
but for this specific model, right?
Let's say the M15 is bullish
and price comes back into an area of interest
where we're with the sweep or the order block
that's pro trend, right?
We come into an area of interest
and in that area of interest,
we get a one minute change of character
and then price moves aggressively, bullish, right?
And it leaves behind a very nice five minute
fair value gap and a five minute order block.
That's what we're gonna take our entry from.
Now, if the one minute timeframe pulls back,
gives a little free kind of pullback and then continues,
we still keep our entry at that point, right?
One of the biggest inefficiencies
that I used to have in the SMC system specifically
is that specific thing.
The reality is, there was an inefficiency
which was a lot of times price would change character,
but then the one minute would continue going,
it would have a little pullback, it would continue going
and then it would also come back down
and now the area that I wanted to get into,
my rule said that I can't get into the area until
we continue a game and change character.
By that time, I'd pretty much already missed the trade.
And so through collection of data
and kind of understanding what's going on
and the variables of the edge,
that's something that I added in,
which again, you're gonna understand
because we're gonna be testing this day in and day out
consistently
and collecting the data, the final thing.
Okay, back into tags.
So we have the different kinds of setups.
We also have a bunch of other things as well.
So I also have execution window.
This is a variable that I wanna test.
I wanna essentially look,
what does the data look like inside of each execution window?
So we have our two to three AM, two to three AM window.
And again, these are one hour windows.
So the two to three AM is the beginning of my London window,
the first hour of my London window.
If I execute a position in that period,
that gets tagged as a two to three AM execution.
Three to four AM, four to five AM, right?
Those are the three different tags
that could occur for my London tabs.
Then we have the New York sales,
which is seven to eight AM, eight to nine AM
or nine to 10 AM in those windows.
Again, I just wanna be lucky in the different variables
of data because who knows?
Maybe at the end of the testing,
I end up coming all the way back,
looking at this data and realizing, huh, you know what?
Like, every time I execute a trade
in that nine to 10 AM window for New York session,
I only have a 20% hit rate or I'm actually unprofitable.
And if you have that, well,
you can remove an inefficiency there and there.
Again, so this is what I mean.
Like these are the, we wanna be looking at the details
so that at the end, we can start filtering
for the different data and looking at different data views
and start to understand how to actually refine
and remove inefficiencies from the edge
to overall make the performance better.
Because a lot of the time,
this is what a lot of traders get wrong,
is they think that making an edge better is adding things.
Sometimes yes, but sometimes no, it's really contextual.
And so before you go adding everything,
you first might wanna look at inefficiencies
because inefficiencies are the fastest way
to unlock, you know, extra profitability.
If you can remove the things that don't work
and just leave the things that do,
you've already unlocked more profitability.
It's the easiest thing and fastest thing to do
to increase your edge.
So we have execution window, we have news, right?
And the way that I tag news is very simple.
Either I close the trade due to a high impact news event.
So for example, I'm trading the London session,
it's NFP day today or a CPI day today.
And I'm in the trade and, you know, New York session opens
and I'm looking to close that trade
before that high impact news event hits
are gonna be out the market.
So sometimes you might see me close that trade.
Now, entered after news.
So if I tag this, this means that I've entered
into a position after usually an 8.30 a.m.
moderately impactful event.
So I think retail sales, right?
Or core PCE, or ADP has just rolled out
and I'm entering a trade off the back of that.
I wanna tag that because again, at the end,
I can come in and be like, okay,
how do my understander of news play a part?
I might find that I'm way more profitable
by simply just not trading any day that has news, right?
I might find that some of my best setups
are actually when I enter off the back
of these moderately impactful news events
because they give the directional clarity.
So again, this is it.
I have an ever tag which is I held that trade
through moderate news, right?
So this is if I hold a trade
through a new session that is moderately impactful.
So if I'm in a position
and that position is running in profit,
I might decide to keep that position open,
especially if we're like 3R in profit or something like that,
I may decide, depending on the context of where I am,
to keep that position open.
And if I do that, I need to be tagging that variable
because I need to see how that plays out at the end.
When I'm collecting that data,
I wanna be seeing these things
because this was gonna enable me
to be able to spot inefficiencies.
And then finally, no news, right?
So this is just very simple
but there is no high impact news that's in this day.
There's no reform news.
So yeah, that's kind of how I'm organizing news,
points of interest.
So again, I wanna get into the intricacies
because not every single setup is the same.
We have different points of interest.
So here, there's four different types of points of interest.
And in fact, I'll move back up to here
to try and just show you these points of interest.
So we have a weak point of interest, right?
That's our first one.
A weak point of interest, very simply put,
is a point of interest that has no impact, right?
So you have an order block or a fair value gap that's created
but it doesn't have an impact.
Now, how do you define impact?
The definition of impact for me
is a break of an important structural level.
So as you can see here, we are, let's say we're bullish, right?
We have a low to a high, we come back
and this low begins to put in a high like this.
It begins attacking this high.
It fails to break this high
and price starts coming back towards it.
Well, to me, that's a weak point of interest
because this area of interest failed to break this high.
And if you just look at it simply
from a supply and demand perspective, right?
Supply steps into the market here,
demand steps into the market here,
not steps in but kind of outweighs.
And price is going down,
there is more supply than the most demand.
If price is coming up, there's more demand
than there is supply.
So supply is in control as price goes down
and then demand starts taking over control.
But we enter back to the old area
where supply was gaining control
and supply regains control does push in price lower.
This makes me question whether the demand interest
in this area is strong.
And the answer for me is, no, it's not.
That doesn't mean I'm not gonna trade from it.
That simply just means that that is a variable
that I want to look at.
Actually, it may become a thing
where a weak point of interest
is my most profitable point of interest, right?
There's no right or wrong just 'cause it's weak and strong
doesn't mean that one is better than the other.
What's gonna tell you what's better than one of the other
is the data and that's what we're after.
And this is why we have to understand this.
And the second version is essentially the same thing
but it's more internal.
So we're bullish, internal structures start trading bearish
and then we have an internal reaction.
From here, that creates a point of interest
that I may want to trade from
and that point of interest fails to break that high.
That's considered a weak point of interest, right?
And then versus a strong point of interest,
very different thing, a strong point of interest
is an area that has an impact, thus breaks something.
So this point of interest, this demand zone,
this further you go, ends up leading
to the break of this previous high, strong.
This one is internal, right?
Let's say we're bullish, price coming down bearish internally
and then we shift bullish internally,
we have a break of a significant structural level,
that for me is a strong point of interest, right?
Then we have a broad point of interest.
So a broad point of interest is essentially
a larger range of orders, right?
So I've got it here as a previous cluster.
And again, you'll see this in more detail
when we go into the backtest.
But you can have a really nice point of interest, right?
This kind of final area in here, right?
Where you have a nice sell to buy
that leaves a fair value gap
and this might be your refined point of interest.
But you can't, you can't not consider the fact
that we may have this broad area of interest in here, right?
From this high to this low down here,
there's this broad area of interest
where the previous kind of auction range is taking place.
And so there's still a lot of orders in this level,
maybe on the 15 minute timeframe,
this is, you know, order block down here for value gap.
But maybe if you go up to an hourly or, you know,
three hour, four hour,
maybe you find that this is the order block
on the four hour timeframe.
Maybe you find that, you know,
this is a four hour value gap, right?
And so those things are still important,
but I've labeled and categorized that area
as a broad point of interest.
Now, know that you will only have a trade
from a broad point of interest,
typically speaking, after a sweep of liquidity.
So it's, again, just an add-up.
And then you have no point of interest.
So a no POI is something that I, you know,
kind of never used to factor in
until, you know, understanding things deeper
and understanding liquidity at a deeper level.
So if, for me, if there was no point of interest,
it just doesn't matter.
But then continuously I see the eliquidation occurs.
And we're in the middle of kind of no man's land,
is why I call it, right?
Which is where you have this kind of previous cluster range
in here, price goes into this expansion phase,
comes back down and then trades from here.
And you're kind of in this no man's land.
So the area from that high to this,
from where price is right now, essentially,
that's kind of, you know, no point of interest.
And again, no POI doesn't necessarily mean that it's bad thing.
Again, no POI could be the most profitable model.
We don't actually not.
And so again, it's just a variable inside of a set-up.
So any set-up could also include some of these, right?
Any of these set-ups that we have here,
any of these set-ups could include these areas.
And so now what we're starting to get
is kind of a formulation,
because now what you can look at is,
you don't have to just look at the quality
of the set-up itself.
Maybe you find that the London Sweep Asia session
has a 50% win rate, right?
That's your highest win rate system.
Maybe you find that your New York continuation
from London POI has a 30% win rate.
Now, if you go deeper into the details
and then you start looking at, okay, well,
what about when I took London Sweep of Asia
with a strong POI or with a weak POI or no POI or broad POI?
You're gonna get a different data cluster.
And that data cluster is gonna tell you a different thing.
And so the data depends on how you want to look at it.
And so this is a game where you can start looking at,
okay, so what I noticed was my London Sweep Asia
for the entire year of back dusting
that had a 50% win rate.
But when I paired that London Sweep Asia
with a strong POI, it had a 65% win rate.
Now all of a sudden I'm starting to understand
my A-plus set-ups.
And then that takes me into the next tagging system, right?
Which is usually trend phase.
And so you'll see in here, we have point of interest.
And then we have the trend, right?
This is the phases of the trend.
And for me, there are three main ones that I want to test.
That is the change of character.
And then this is essentially when the M15 swing range
is formed, in fact, I'll just show you them.
So you have the first phase of a trend,
which is just a change of character.
So we're always trading with the directional bias of the M15.
But we can understand what phase of structure
is that M15 net?
Because if we've just had a change of character
and the leg we're trading inside of
is come from a change of character,
then that's gonna be the categorization
of a change of character.
If it's gonna be a trend confirmation,
which is essentially a change of character
and another break of structure,
this becomes a confirmed trend.
Then that's in of itself, a structural leg, right?
And then you have what I consider a trending market,
which is anything over the second break of structure.
So if you have a change of character,
then a break of structure, you confirm trend,
third break of structure,
anything after that you're trending.
You're in a trending market, right?
And again, there may be no statistical differentiation
by looking at these tags,
but we don't know that until we have the data.
You already have, again,
especially if you kind of understand things,
you already have an idea of a hypothesis,
of the things you think will have the biggest difference.
But the reality is,
I'm a huge advocate for let the data decide.
I see a lot of traders,
and we'll probably go through to some point.
A lot of traders will come into the community
and they'll come into the community area
and they'll ask a question like,
"Hey, I'm thinking of one to three risk reward fixed
instead of one to five risk reward."
Or, "Hey, I'm thinking about going to break even
after this happens instead of this.
What do you guys think?"
And the reality is,
is any answer that you're going to get
is inaccurate relative to data.
Because I can sit there and tell you,
"You know what, yeah, I mean, hypothetically,
that makes sense.
I can see where you're coming from.
It's understandable.
I can see the logic,
but does the market deal in hypotheticals?"
No, it deals in data.
And so people have a question.
My answer is always, "I don't know.
Let the data decide."
I don't know.
If I haven't ran that test, I can't tell you.
And a lot of mentors, gurus, people out there,
if you ask them a question like,
"Hey, you know, what about this?"
They'll be like, "Oh, no, no, no.
Don't worry about that.
That doesn't work."
"Oh, what about this?"
They're like, "Yeah, yeah, that will make everything better.
That's definitely the one.
Go for that."
And it's like, "How do you know?"
You don't.
You don't know anything until you've tested it.
And so again, let the data decide.
So that's trend phase.
And we have structural flow.
Structural flow is pretty simple.
There are three different types.
There is pro-trend only.
So pro-trend only is when there is no internal structure.
You are bullish and there's no internal structure.
You're bearish and there's no internal structure.
So when you're tagging a trade, its own is pro-trend only.
Now you may have counter-internal.
Counter-internal is your bullish,
but the internal structure is bearish
and now you take a long position.
And then obviously pro-internal is when you're bullish
and the internal was bearish
and then it shifts bullish.
And so now you have a bullish external and bullish internal
or bearish external and bearish internal.
And this is a really interesting one
because by understanding this,
what you might again see potentially who knows is again,
it's all part of being a scientist in some sense.
As you may come back in here and you may be like,
"Hey, you know what I find?
When I take my Frank Sweep London continuation model,
it has a 30% win rate.
But if I take that model when we're also pro-internal,
it has a 60% win rate.
Or maybe you come in there
and you're like, the Frank Sweep London,
the Frank Sweep Asia continuation model
has a negative profit expectancy.
I mean, it's actually unprofitable.
But then you add in a data filtration,
which is looking at if you take that trade,
what about if we're pro-internal?
What about if we're working from a strong point of interest?
And as long as you have enough examples of that trade,
you don't want to just be running off
one or two different examples,
then what you may find is that actually no,
you do have a model there.
And now you kind of come to redefine it
and this is the refinement process.
So you're premium in discount, right?
Premium in discount isn't something that you must follow.
It's something that could add an additional layer
of confluence to your setups.
But I've always told people like premium in discount
is a extra confluence, right?
That's what I tell people.
But is it?
Like I don't know.
So let's test it, right?
From my personal experience,
I found that I do have a better experience
when I'm longing from an area of discounting price
or when I'm sure from an area of premium price, for sure.
But what about in the context
of the different types of setups that we have
that may not necessarily be true?
And so again, just like it's pretty simple,
there's a tag, it's premium in discount.
Is it premium in discount?
Yes or no?
If it's in premium in discount,
that simply just means that if we are long,
then we are longing from an area of discount.
And if we are short,
we are shorting from an area of premium.
If it's no, then it's we're long
and we're longing from an area of premium.
And if we are short,
we are shorting from an area of discount, right?
And so those are the real main kind of contextual understanding
that I have to give you to show you what they are.
Again, if this is all going over your head,
don't worry about it.
Like we're gonna be going for this consistently
and you'll see everything come back full circle.
If you have to watch it more times,
you have to watch it more times, don't worry about it.
So, and then finally, we have the session.
So we have London session and we have New York session.
Now this is really a much more unnecessary tag.
Can we tell the answer to you?
Because trade seller will give me the data anyway
of my trade times, but I just wanna tag it.
This is execution, executed in London session,
executed in New York session.
That's it.
And that pretty much brings us full circle, right?
We have the trend, we have the structure flow,
internal pro, internal counter.
We have the different types of setups of the sessions.
We have our premium discount, yes or no.
Point of interest, is it strong?
Is it weak? Is it broad? Is it no POI?
We have the news, right?
And we have the execution window.
And so now we have the playbook.
So these are the rules that we're gonna be following
regardless, but we're gonna be filtering that playbook
with these different variants, right?
Which are tags.
And so now everything in that playbook
is gonna be broken down into most importantly,
the different quality of setups.
I might go in there and find that actually, you know,
I've got seven different types of setups I could take,
but only three of them are profitable.
And if I've achieved, you know,
a hundred percent return year to date,
and only three of those setups are actually profitable,
the others are unprofitable,
simply just by removing those setups.
I will spend less time on the market
because I will take less trades.
And by the way, you know,
a lot of people are like,
"Oh, I don't want to take less trades."
It's like, "Do you want to take less losing trades?"
Of course you do.
My ideal life is like,
get as much as I can with as little as I need to do.
It's pretty simple.
So I don't want to trade every single day.
If you come to me and you said, "Hey, you know,
"here are two systems."
One system takes, one system you'll have, you know,
two trades a week, right?
Between these periods of time,
and you just need to be able to essentially understand
and mark out your levels, set alerts, and, you know,
trade this.
You don't have to be sitting there all day, every day,
two setups a week.
And those two setups,
they're going to return you, you know, 50% for the year.
And someone else says, "Hey, here's a system."
You're going to have,
you're going to be able to take, you know,
two trades a day in the same time window.
But you're going to have to be there way more focused,
locked in because it could happen at any time.
So I'm spending more time taking more trades,
which is essentially the higher probability of failure, right?
The more trades I take,
the higher the probability that I'm going to make a mistake,
essentially, right?
Because I have more shots to miss, right?
There's more chances for me to make, you know,
the more chances for me to be emotional,
especially the more trades are taken.
So for me, an ideal world,
like if you said to me, one trade a year,
and you're going to do, you know, X amount of a percent,
maybe I'm being a little bit extreme,
but I think you kind of get the purpose
and the importance of what I'm trying to get at.
So I believe that, you know,
I don't believe that more is better or less is better.
I believe that more could be better and less could be better,
but I believe in the data side.
So that is pretty much my playbook.
Those, this is how we're going to be running the test.
This is how we're going to be organizing the data.
Those are the specifics of all of that.
Now we're going to take all that information.
We're going to go and back test this specific model
for the entirety of 2024
and probably get also the year to date 2025 done as well.
And we'll see how everything plays out.
I'll be with you step by step,
taking every single trade
and we'll be reviewing the data together
and kind of making sense of everything.
And again, this entire purpose is number one, yes,
give you an edge that works, obviously.
But number two is to show you how
to really think, behave, move, act,
be a professional trading operator.
So I'll see you guys in the next episode.